carrying on in the twenty joe saburi
in detail 17 and 18
and next and uh
they're the last two in the hasso series
as with the others you can choose
if you do
standard passo
or if you do the
passover this way across the body
this one you can use the body
and slide with it
this would be seen in the kentai joe
when cytosensit shows you the the joe
exercises
so we have this one
i won't go full three but um
so you get very similar movements and
actions
with the joe as this passo that i've
introduced you to earlier
[Music]
h
you're striking to their knee you can
try two ways here as well as the
angle of the hasso getting into the
hassle
you can do a showman if you wish to try
it for just a straight cut to the
person's head
or to the side of their
knee
okay
yeah you have this leaning out
feeling this leaning out feeling because
it's
it's coming from here
it's coming off the head the same as you
would for showman
same as you would for shown when you're
up white white comes
off here
and this foot then moves and you adjust
trade
so
hey
so try to feel it
be one with your joe feel it be one with
your jaw
the hand swivels the whole thing
is an intricate intricated movement
of your whole being everything must be
expressional and feeling it beautiful
movement within it
[Music]
so the hasso that comes across this way
is more flowing in an expressional way
the standard one
i tend to now push out look
under my own armpit
turn
strike
shifting weight shifting weight
three
they say doing something ten thousand
times or ten thousand hours
uh teaches you it how to do it
seems to be you know a new thing
recently in anything that you do
but if you do it wrong it's better to
do it one thousand times right than 10
000 times
without knowing the correct way so i
hope this
has showing you some various
understandings
feelings and please mimic me and see if
you can find
what i find within this
shadow
hey
foreign